with a show that's been around as long
as Dragonball you better believe there
have been some incredible moments that
have taken us completely by surprise
whether it's action comedy or story this
series has provided some truly
jaw-dropping moments and so I have
decided to organize all of my favorite
surprises from Dragon Ball Dragon Ball Z
and Dragon Ball super into one handy
dandy list for your viewing pleasure so
let's get started number ten what better
way to start off this list and what I
think is it arguably the weirdest death
in the entire franchise
it is a genuine travesty that this
Jackie Chan scene is remembered fondly
and that this absolute masterpiece of
fight choreography is lost to time jokes
aside though when I first saw this
magnificent scene I was indeed shocked
both in a good and a terrified way so
here it is topping off the list at
number 10 and if you don't like it then
I guess you don't have any taste get it
number 9 dragon ball super wasn't up
down and up again roller coaster that
had more than its fair share of
surprising moments not the least of
which was freezes last-minute
substitution for majin buu in the
universe 17 living in the age of the
Internet as I was this news was spoiled
for me before I even had a chance to see
it unfold in the anime however the fact
that just reading the news in text form
alone about this was enough to send
shockwaves through my system should tell
you everything you need to know about
how impactful this creative choice was
to the series and that's why it sits
pretty as our number 9 number 8 okay
let's set the scene the year is 2001
five ten years old the Garlic Junior
Saga had just finished we haven't seen
Goku since the climax of the frieza saga
and now the man himself Frieza and his
daddy dearest our front and center on
planet Earth ready to destroy it and not
a single one of the Earth's defenses
were strong enough to do anything all
looked grim until
[Music]
this moment was enormous for the series
not only do we have a new Saiyan not
only does he slice and dice Frieza and
his father but we now have a new Super
Saiyan
pretty surprising stuff but not nearly
surprising as our next entry number 7
all right this one might seem a little
weird but only because 99.9% of everyone
on earth started watching Dragon Ball
with Dragon Ball Z ok those stats might
be a little bit off regardless this was
an earth-shattering moment when it first
aired this turned the entire story of
Dragon Ball on its head
what was once a story about a
happy-go-lucky monkey boy turned into a
grand space epic where the protagonist
Goku is now an alien and has an evil
older brother called Raddatz I know it
sounds corny as all hell now but believe
you me back in the day this turned quite
a few heads number 6 coming in at number
6 we have everyone's favorite fat man
with a sword
yeah gob swooping in to save the day
cutting off Vegeta's tail this was one
of the very first episodes I ever
watched and consequently was one of the
first surprises Dragon Ball ever laid
before me and I absolutely loved it
despite us all knowing yeah gob was in
the area he never once participated in
the fight
in fact he actively avoided it Vegeta's
fight with Goku as it progressed got
more and more fierce episode by episode
and so when Vegeta was raging as a news
arrow nothing on earth would have been
more surprising to me as a kid that
forgot a role betta caught in and even
the playing field with a well-placed and
timed slash of his sword and now a quick
message from our sponsor for the holiday
season I've teamed up with geek nations
net to bring you guys an exclusive free
giveaway right now they're offering free
dragon ball hats only available through
the link in the description all you've
got to do is follow the link in the
description add the Hat to your cart and
begin to check out however keep in mind
there are shipping fees and only one hat
is allowed per customer
but it's that easy and if you see
anything else you'd like you can use
coupon code mark for 10% off anything in
store stock solo when this offer will
only last until the end of the year or
until they run out so grab a hat if
you're looking for some dragon ball
style in 2019 number 5 ok now we're on
the business end of the list and this
one is one of my favorites reckon
by most as the first great moment of
Dragon Ball super in episode 39 of the
series Goku finds himself in a complete
mismatch against hit the assassin from
universe 6 in a last-ditch effort to
close the energy gap goku boasts that he
has one last trick up his sleeve
neither hit nor us the audience know
what he's talking about until he says he
okay this clip is amazing to watch with
the entire arena almost set on fire by
Goku's red and blue aura with the series
having been put in a negative light that
year this moment certainly took more
than a few people by surprise number 4
this is the only moment on this list
that has actually fooled me twice in my
lifetime so let's break it down we are
at the very end of the frito saga
most of the namekians are dead all of
freezes soldiers are dead ten days dead
Vegeta is dead and the only person who
stands a chance against Frieza and
believe you me I use the term chance
extremely loosely here is Goku up until
now the fight has been quite even with
both sides getting good hits it however
out of nowhere Frieza declares that he
hasn't been using much of his power at
all and claims that 50% will be more
than enough to deal with Goku what
follows is the slow and hard to look at
dismantling of Goku at the hands of
Frieza and I mean it there are some
savage shots in this scene however as a
viewer we always keep a checklist of
power-ups our heroes have in their back
pocket such as in the case of Goku the
kaio-ken a move that multiplies the
user's power by a declared amount so we
were worried about Goku in this moment
but we also knew he still had this until
King Kai goes on to explain that
throughout this savage beatdown Goku had
been using the kaio-ken times 10 that
blew my mind as a kid and when I watched
it again as an adult great twist great
episode number 3 this one is pretty
self-explanatory but man does it kick
ass goku vs self the big showdown or
what we thought was the biggest showdown
at the time it sees goku looking down
its cell as he begins to charge his
kamehameha
friends blow worried that his blast will
destroy the earth and sell remarks the
same thinking that there's no way Goku
will do this and just as Goku fires his
blast
Goku teleports right in front of Sal
obliterating the upper half of his body
into pieces definitely surprised me the
first time I saw it and it's one that
has found its way into literally every
Dragonball a MV that has ever been made
in the history of everything ever number
2 up until this point Dragon Ball super
had been criticized as being too
kid-friendly without enough stakes so
Joey decides to take it upon themselves
to bring us to the post-apocalyptic
future trunks world they decided to kill
future Bulma in a pretty horrific way
and they convinced us all that future
mine was dead but that's not even the
most surprising part then this happens I
cannot tell you the storm of theory is
an intrigue that spread across the
internet when this big reveal was aired
an evil Goku it for sure took me
off-guard but not quite as much as our
next entry number one if I read down
below in the comments section something
like Oh mark I totally saw this one
coming you may be handsome and smart and
I may want to donate to your patreon but
this was totally not surprising first of
all thank you patreon link is in the
description but you sir are either a
bold-faced liar blind or a bold-faced
blind liar yeah it's been a long
established mechanic that beings in the
world of Dragon Ball are more likely to
push something than they are to explode
an impact but my little brain was not
ready for what it bared witness to when
it came to the climax of Goku vs.
Catholic my 26 year old self literally
jumped out of my chair spilling all of
my delicious special case cereal I was
eating thus flooding my desk with milk I
didn't care nothing I had ever seen in
Dragon Ball even came close to
surprising me as much as this did it was
an incredible idea that I was surprised
a handful of sooner such a beautiful
elegant moment when waiting this video I
had to cut out a bunch of moments from
this list that were both shocking and
surprising in their own
so if your most surprising moment from
this series wasn't featured here be sure
to let me know what it was in the
comments down below and maybe I'll make
a new list in the future who knows don't
forget to leave a like if you enjoyed
and subscribe for more content like this
I'll see you guys next time and thank
you so much for watching
[Music]